hey 42 here
three days before Christmas in 2010 76
year old Michael faherty died in a house
fire in the picturesque Irish city of
Galway
people die in house fires all too often
but this case was unusual
what was once Michael's body was now a
pile of Ash as though he'd been consumed
by a Towering Inferno but that made
absolutely no sense because aside from
the armchair in which his body was found
the rest of his house was practically
untouched
investigators were also struggling to
figure out how the fire had started
there was no source of flame nearby nor
a trace of excelivant to Mr debris
stranger still a foul-smelling oily
residue coated the walls and ceilings of
the entire ground floor
to put it mildly the entire incident was
a mystery a mystery that deepened when
the coroner declared that Michael had
died from spontaneous human combustion
are you tired of spending precious time
preparing meals when you have a really
busy schedule I know I am well let me
introduce you to huel Black Edition your
super nutritional Time Saver huel Black
Edition is a 100 nutritionally complete
meal that's plant-based gluten-free and
high in protein with low carbs it's
packed with 26 essential vitamins and
minerals and it's ready in just 30
seconds to make a heel Shake I simply
add 500 mL of water to my heel shaker
bottle add two scoops of fuel powder and
give it a good shake my personal
favorite is the black edition cookies
and cream I can't believe that stuff is
actually good for me because it's really
rich and chocolatey it's so good I
especially like to start my day on
protein because protein is so essential
to pretty much every function of the
body and a protein-packed breakfast puts
my body on the right track for the rest
of today each serving of fuel contains a
massive 40 grams of protein and loads of
fiber with less than 5 sugar oh did I
mention it's also really affordable so
click the link in the description to try
heal today if you use my special link
you'll be supporting the channel and
you'll also get a free heel shaker
bottle so don't miss out and thanks to
huel for sponsoring this video
in other words Michael fahati hadn't
been the tragic victim of a house fire
he was the house fire strange though it
was Michael's death is far from unique
cases of spontaneous human combustion
people bursting into flames without an
external source of ignition have been
chronicled for centuries
one of the first was in 1731 when
Italian Countess Cornelia bandi went to
bed feeling unwell
the following morning her bed chamber
was covered in an oily residue and a
pile of Ash was found by the bed the
noble woman's body had been almost
entirely devoured by what must have been
a very small very concentrated fire all
that was left were her lower legs and
few stray fingers
one of the more famous victims is Mary
Riza a 67 year old Florida resident
whose apartment became her funeral pyre
in 1951. her landlady noticed that the
door handler was hot to the touch and
discovered Mary's charred remains inside
only her left foot still wearing a
slipper survived the blaze once again
the walls and ceilings were covered in a
smelly oily residue
these are just a couple of examples
amongst hundreds of strangely similar
cases all sharing a few key details one
the victim's bodies are almost entirely
destroyed by the fire even the bones two
the lower legs and feet usually survive
completely unharmed and often still
wearing unburnt clothing or shoes three
a mysterious oily residue is found on
surfaces nearby and for the unusually
localized fire that caused the damage
appears to have no external Source it
seems the victims just burst into flames
so what the hell is going on here well
we still don't know for sure but some
have blamed excessive alcoholism whilst
others have deemed it to be divine
retribution dished out to Sinners that
was the angle Charles Dickens went with
when he killed off alcoholic Rag and
Bone man and all-round [__] Mr Crook
in his novel Bleak House
other theories include Poltergeist
activity a buildup of static electricity
ball lightning and the effects of an
Undiscovered subatomic particle
tentatively titled the pyrotron or
possibly just holding in your farts you
can thank South Park for that one there
is of course another school of thought
that the entire idea human beings can
just burst into flames at random is
complete horse piss as for who's right
well the answer to that question might
just surprise you let's start by
highlighting the obvious here we know
humans can combust because we burn
millions of them every year in
crematoriums it's just a spontaneous
part that's controversial
we also know spontaneous combustion in
general is possible for example
exothermic reactions in large piles of
compost or hay it can generate enough
heat to ignite suddenly and the same can
be said if coal charcoal and cotton so
humans burn and sometimes things
randomly catch on fire is spontaneous
human combustion really such a stretch
actually yeah it kind of is as of today
there is quite simply no proven process
by which a human body which is roughly
60 water could suddenly catch on fire
for that reason the vast majority of
scientists discounts the notion of truly
spontaneous human combustion a 1984
study of 30 historical cases found that
almost all the bodies were discovered
near some kind of flame an open fire a
candle a lit pipe that sort of thing
they also found that many of the victims
were smokers and almost all were elderly
had serious health conditions or were
alcoholics
the conclusion was pretty simple a stray
Ember from a nearby fire or a dropped
cigarette lands in the victim's lap and
they're either too old too ill or too
drunk to react before the Fire gets out
of hand take Mary Riza as a prime
example she was a heavy smoker who took
sleeping pills whilst spontaneous human
combustion can't be ruled out it's much
more likely that she fell into a pill
induced sleep whilst holding a lit
cigarette and thermodynamics did the
rest
it's also a bit bloody suspicious that
the vast majority of victims
spontaneously combust when they're home
alone without any Witnesses in the age
of the smartphone and Big Brother style
CCTV If people really could just catch
on fire for no reason you'd expect to
see some decent footage you've been
framed to pay good money for that kind
of thing
proponents of spontaneous human
combustion frequently cite incidents
where no source of fire was found nearby
but as Carl Sagan once said absence of
evidence does not mean evidence of
absence in other words just because an
external source of ignition isn't found
near the body it doesn't mean there
wasn't One to begin with whatever
sparked the fire could have been
completely consumed by the subsequent
flames
okay so case closed right it's all just
a myth well let's not get ahead of
ourselves because even if the
spontaneous party is starting to look a
little sus what happens after that is
still utterly baffling
as we've seen the remains left behind in
these cases are very distinctive the
Torso is utterly destroyed whilst the
legs or Feats survive
[Music]
crematorium furnaces reach temperatures
approaching 1000 degrees Celsius for
roughly 90 minutes to incinerate your
average human using a tremendous amount
of fuel in the process even then
fragments of bone remain that have to be
mechanically pulverized so here's the
million dollar question how could a mere
cigarette or errant Ember falling onto
someone's lap achieve similar results to
an industrial furnace
and how can a fire that's hot and hot
enough on bone
leave other parts of the body
bodiedly untouched
not only is his stuff seriously weird
it's also the exact opposite of what we
typically see with victims of house
fires normally the limbs go first and
the Torso tends to survive
for a long time these twin enigmas
remained unexplained until an unexpected
Source provided a clue The Humble candle
everyone knows how candles work the wax
provides a steady flow of fuel which is
delivered to the flame by way of the
wick resulting in a slow even burn that
can last for hours
something similar could be happening
with spontaneous human combustion a
spark ignites a victim's clothing which
acts like the wick and then the wax AKA
fuel is supplied by human body fat which
is highly flammable if a small clothing
fire is left unchecked because the
victim is incapacitated or already dead
from natural causes the skin beneath
could rupture allowing melting body fats
to seep into the clothing the fat would
fuel a fire which melts more fat and
just perpetuates the cycle until there's
no more fuel to burn
in effect the victim becomes a human
candle
this gruesome process is known as the
wick effect and it illuminates a lot of
the weirdness we've seen so far a small
intense fire with a low flame that won't
easily spread Beyond this source of fuel
seems like the perfect fit for
spontaneous human combustion the
distinctive destruction of the Torso
also starts to make sense that's where
we carry most of our body fat the legs
survive partly because they're below the
fire where it's considerably cooler and
partly because they don't contain enough
fat to fuel the flames
the wick effect also explains where that
odd Brown residue comes from gruesomely
enough it's just partially burnt body
fat but as good as the wick effect
appears to be in explaining All The
Oddities of these cases there is one
small problem
in 2016 BBC's Earth lab conducted an
experiment to demonstrate the efficacy
of the wick effect on a human body but
things didn't proceed as planned they
wrapped a dead pig in a blanket and
dropped a cigarette onto the fabric
a fire began to smolder almost
immediately but it proved too small to
melt the body fat Below in the end the
team had to intervene by dousing the
fire in a liquid accelerant and actively
Fanning the Flames two things that most
certainly would not happen in the real
world
the wick effect did eventually kick in
creating a small self-sustaining fire
focused on the Torso which burnt for six
hours straight
the pattern of burning was shockingly
similar to spontaneous human combustion
but the damage was far less severe the
pig and blanket was nicely charred and
would have been lovely with your
Christmas turkey but it was nowhere near
turning into a pile of Ash
now it may simply be that the experiment
wasn't close enough to the real thing
and pig is a pretty good substitute for
a human but it isn't perfect
nevertheless it did cast doubts doubts
which only grow when you explore some of
the more extreme cases of spontaneous
human combustion
on a September evening in 1982 Genie
safin was sitting at the kitchen table
of her parents house in North London
with her father and brother-in-law when
she suddenly caught fire
according to the brother-in-law Genie
was engulfed by a raging Inferno within
seconds there were even flames shooting
out of her mouth smog Style
she died in hospital not long afterwards
in another case five years later what
remained of Barry Sudan was found on his
kitchen floor in Folkston Kent as we've
seen before Barry was but a big pile of
ass with a couple of feet sticking out
it should have been a textbook case of
the wick effect in action except for one
small problem bubbling away on the Hub
nearby was a pan of water
it's forced the wick effect requires
roughly 12 hours to reduce the human to
Ash but if Barry had been burning away
for half a day or more why hadn't the
pot on the stove boil dry
other victims appear to have been fully
conscious when meeting their
spontaneously fiery fate homeless man
Robert Bailey was found in an abandoned
building in London in 1967. his still
burning body was bent in agony at the
foot of a flight of stairs and
disappeared he'd been writhing around
before succumbing to the Flames his pain
had been so great that he'd bitten into
a solid wooden banister so forcefully
that firefighters had to pry his jaw
open
it doesn't take forensic science to suss
that the wick effect alone cannot
explain these cases so what are we
missing according to research biologist
Brian Ford the final piece of this
Macabre puzzle is of all things nail
polish remover
Ford was never convinced that Wick
effect alone could turn a non-flammable
human into a pile of Ash overnight so he
tried to come up with feasible scenarios
that could increase our body's
flammability and it turns out he
actually found one
when the human body is start of
carbohydrates it begins to burn stored
fat instead the resulting metabolic
state is called ketosis because it
results in elevated levels of Ketone
bodies in the bloodstream and urine one
of which is acetone the key ingredient
in nail polish remover
acetone is extremely flammable and can
accumulate in fatty tissues at high
concentrations during ketosis Ford
believes that under the right
circumstances a person in ketosis may
become flammable to test his theory he
made a bunch of tiny model humans out of
pork meat marinated overnight in acetone
as you do he dressed these mini meat men
in tiny clothes then set them on fire
every single one of them burnt to Ash in
under 30 minutes leaving only their
limbs behind notably Ford's pork
soldiers burned with a bright blue flame
most spontaneous human combustions
happen behind closed doors but the few
folks who have witnessed one almost
always mention blue flames incidentally
the low Flames produced by the wick
effect are invariably Orange it's pretty
compelling evidence but once again
questions remain ketosis isn't an
elusive metabolic State most of us
experience it on a fairly regular basis
after a session at the gym when we're
ill or when we haven't eaten for a while
plenty of people enter ketosis on
purpose in an attempt to burn fat and
lose weight
it's called the keto diet
so if ketosis really does make the human
body flammable why isn't some poor soul
going up like a firework every five
minutes
for now we don't have a good answer to
that question if you're starting to spot
a pattern I'm right there with you there
simply isn't enough evidence to either
confirm or debunk any of these theories
cases of spontaneous human combustion
are incredibly rare and since burning
old people is apparently considered
unethical it's difficult to create
meaningful experiments in the lab
we can probably rule out the more
extreme theories but there isn't really
enough evidence to definitively confirm
the more sensible ones either so yeah
all I can say is until we meet again
please please try really hard not to
burst into flames
thanks for watching